to fire watch now and new concerns as we  get closer to summer here in the desert  fire officials say dry brush and soil  could lead to  more wildfires this season a new climate  study says the moisture content in  western states  it is lower than it's been in 125 years  meteorologists at noaa say the soil here  in the west and especially in california  is record dry for this time of year  we've had  some years some very very dry periods  such as around you know around 2015  where downtown los angeles hardly  received any rainfall at all for the  winter season  and because of the lack of rain brush  that hasn't burned in decades can easily  fuel a fire so we're getting back into  that season again